i really think it's really nice to be a
tight-knit company
um and i also think that as a tight-knit
company i think things run faster like i
don't want to get to the point where
things are heavy to move you know you
want to keep them going fast and you
want the quick action and the ability to
keep up with the pace of the industry
and even beat it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
let's talk about gaming meet keren
magoom the co-founder and chief
operating officer of beach bomb
karen is a co-founder and ceo of beach
bomb a social gaming company karen was
born and raised in new york to israeli
parents and decided at the age of 22
following her studies to move to israel
on her own family is still in new york
she has a pre-law ba degree and a
master's in business administration mba
in new york karen manages beach bum's
operations including its hr finance
legal as well as its marketing
activities
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you
thanks for having me i'm doing great how
are you
good good i'm doing well i am talking
about social games online games looking
at a you know an industry that is
that is evolving in such a fast pace
that i can't i can't begin to keep track
beach bomb is is such a cool company
i've gotten to play some of the games
myself and i'm already addicted and i
can only try to speculate what it's like
being a co-founder initially chief
revenue officer transitioning to chief
operating officer after also having held
a really important position in some
fantastic organizations prior to this a
lot lots of things to talk about but can
before we even dive into beach bomb and
you know the whole story there
how if you're thinking through your own
career and your own trajectory how how
do you define it how do you you know how
do you think through your career
um i think first of all i think where i
came from i'm american born and raised
moved to israel
at the age of 22 after i did my second
degree in mba
and
i was searching for myself it's very
hard at that point to know what you
really want to do
and i decided to jump into marketing i
started off in high tech but offline
marketing which was nice but
not exciting because when you can't
really measure things it's a little bit
more frustrating and then i joined what
does that mean offline marketing is that
is that you know billboards and direct
mail and stuff like that
yeah more like a conference where you're
going and you're proactively selling and
it's less measurable you know you have
um
also entirely you know going to
different companies trying b2b
um but not through the typical online
channels
so
uh after that i i felt like it was time
to move on and i joined a company where
i was the first employee a company
called mitomi
and i was the first employee they hired
and i was there for 10 years so if i
look at my career path it was amazing to
be
yeah it was really an advent adventure
and
to see how a company
which i really believed in and it was
the entire
issue that i had with the previous
company of being offline suddenly
someone's pitching me how it can be
measured and
so i joined early on and we grew the
company really nicely different mergers
different acquisitions you know a year
there felt like
really like five
and so when i left there after a while i
felt
yeah it's really nice to be on the media
side and you learn a lot but um i was
ready to go to the product side and
really feel
the actual marketing activity and see
the entire funnel of what the impact is
on the company on the product
and so i joined beach women 2015
where
it was just an idea that gigen ori
founded the company um implementing this
idea of going into
head-to-head games in the traditional
i guess the traditional board game
sector right so it was maybe the least
sexy when it comes to all the types of
games out there right there's you know
social casino
and many different activities that are
going on
but here we really took the excitement
of social games and we brought them into
the traditional
offline games in a digital version
and so if we're looking back at you know
you know
what is how do you synthesize through
the thesis
of you know what you were coming up with
you're looking at you know these offline
games that are that are you know casual
they're social and and
what is sort of the thesis around them
as you're positioning big bomb as a
company
i would say the thesis is that there are
so many games companies out there that
generate you know that are profitable
and they don't have nearly the
excitement or the user experience uh
coming into them
as the exciting versions and exciting
categories of gaming that we all know
and love
and so
we basically implemented we revived them
in a way that made it more than just a
backgammon game you come in you go into
this whole ecosystem where you have the
whole gaming experience
and
starting with that also head to head is
very challenging you know most of these
games are
most of them i would say are versus a
computer
so you lose the excitement of the social
channel and playing against your friend
and
really
we've seen so much of the activity and
that was the number one request before
we had the play with friends feature
that was the number one request of all
players of all of our games
and so we really wanted to take
advantage of that niche and run forward
and we showed ourselves that even the
targets that we thought we could reach
were
low balling you know we can do so much
more
now it's that's a perfect subway i think
to to you know my
predicament you know you're coming in as
a co-founder and true revenue officer
you're finding yourself now at this
inflection point where you're you're
starting to develop these games
what is sort of the role of a chief
revenue officer at that moment how do
you you know how do you know which kpis
to set how do you know you know how you
know how high you should aim and how do
you know whether you're reaching the
milestones that you're even setting for
yourself whether they're too high too
low or just about right
such a good question um
in general you know when i first started
out it was really running the business
side making sure that we maximize
the revenue that we can really
find ways uh
to bring the return on ad spend quicker
see the whole funnel of users how we can
analyze things and understand
where we're losing them how do we boost
retention all the kpis the typical
gaming kpis you know uh dao mao arp dao
you want to make sure you have the
highest average revenue per daily active
user
this oh it's a whole bible of all these
different acronyms
and
basically the idea is really to find a
way to
it's just like any other app right right
you want to keep the users you want to
keep them for as long as you can and
that's also part of you know as per your
prior question the thesis that's the
idea of these games the retention of
these games is very high over the long
run uh they're not just here for a month
and leaving they we have users from 2016
who are still in the app and and even
more
active than they were in 2016. so it's
really nice and
yeah and the role at the time was really
monitoring the whole function of the
game right seeing the game economy
seeing the user flow
making sure the crm side is interesting
enough for users to keep going with us
um making sure that you know connecting
between the tech and the marketing and
over time that position definitely
evolved we become more
savvy on the analytics side we've become
more savvy on many different areas i
think
we were all hand-picked right everyone
came with a different background and a
different
history so that together we really made
up a really strong team
and so
walk me through if you
as much as you can remember you know in
2015 it says a long time ago
what does the day
today look like for a co-founder and
chief revenue officer
of of a gaming company you know you wake
up you come to the office
what do you do as a chief revenue
officer
uh
okay well i came from
my previous role it was i'm
a very fast-paced individual okay so i
like action i like being super busy
um and going into
a startup
again
um
is a very different pace because on one
hand you want to run really really fast
on the other hand i remember discussions
with my previous ceo
um telling him i'm not used to the space
you know i like running faster because
suddenly you're dependent on the product
being live in order for you to actually
have
the job to do
so really in the very beginning it was
it was just setting up the
infrastructure you know getting ready to
market things getting ready
with the user experience even within the
app preparing the whole funnel with the
messaging to the new users before they
come and you're just waiting for this
baby to be born
and you're still pregnant so you're just
waiting and overall um
it was
it was definitely challenging but
quickly and like fast you very quickly
get into the
into the
mood and into the
the hang of things
um
and you basically
really
just prepare the ground you know you're
an all-around player at that time
we had organizations very organized on
the one hand we knew the core roles
that we needed to fill and much of my
time went towards hr and building the
team
you know who do we want in order to run
the analytics to run the crm
and all these different
key roles and so
and
basically you're just running in any
direction that you looking forward at
the vision what will help you get there
you know whether it's something from
purchasing the domain of the name of the
game that you want to
hiring a ceo who we didn't have at the
time
you know
amazing and so you know
if you're looking at the next six years
you know fast forward we know where
beejbom is today and the incredible
success that's going on over there
nearly
200 employees and creating some
fantastic games with amazing engagement
and retention
what what happened there you know if
you're looking back what are some of the
big milestones for beach bum
and how did you experience them as the
company grew
i think the biggest milestones
are definitely the number one would be
the team coming together um
whether it's orie and gigi coming up
with you know ori shakhak who's the
platika founder giggy levy who many
people definitely heard he was a
political investor
and an angel investor and
basically it was their starting point
bringing us on board um myself shahar
and gilly who were basically there
um
i guess you know ori said he wanted to
be the grandfather of the company right
because after
after exiting with plating i think he
wanted to be a beach bum himself
and so we basically
got the
authority to run forward and make it
work and
definitely the milestone was actually
bringing the outsourced technology
in-house you know finding a way to have
the three of us work really close
together
and
run forward um additional milestones are
definitely the investments where
you know you get to the point where you
have to make decisions do we push this
product even more
in gaming you could be very profitable
if you don't
do marketing right
but you're not looking necessarily for
the long term so when you see that you
can return a certain percentage of the
marketing spend within a few months then
you just want to run
and so you need to get more fuel so the
investments were definitely
a milestone um having a really
strong tight board
um
made up of origin two of our major
investors 83 north and saban ventures so
that was something that was really good
having the freedom to run and do what we
thought was best
every game launch is a milestone and
it's an exciting day i remember every
day we launched
a new game
also we try to make the milestones
the small wins you know with all of our
running we need to really stop and enjoy
every time we hit a new
target or a new
um
peak in the game's revenue and so
basically we just keep running
um and obviously you know the
acquisition is a huge milestone which
we're really proud of
and and so
when you used to release the games that
anything happened in the offices or what
was sort of the vibe you know i i want
to try to be there what happened during
those days when you were releasing those
games
oh it was really exciting um
in the beginning i remember
you know we walked in we had all of us
in the office and all the excitement and
we would do you know we would set up a
head-to-head so you want to have many
people in the game so we would set up
you know we would just sit and play the
whole office would just sit and play and
we'd get very excited when we saw you
know friends of ours come online and
suddenly we would play against them
because you know when we started out and
you don't have marketing then most of
the friends and family are the ones who
come out on the first day
um
we had said hours that we told our
friends and family to come on and play
so that they can get the hang of it i
remember the day when a friend of mine
came over my house you know we had a set
hour to do it and
she went suddenly against the
customer support rep so she got so
excited it's this wow factor to see
someone play against someone they know
um
and besides that i think
it was really the excitement of seeing
it actually pan out seeing them
go through every kpi you know playing
the game
uh sticking to the game when we had
someone purchasing and they put in you
know five dollars we got so excited and
when we have someone put in a hundred
dollars we said we got our first will
you know
and um it's just really
seeing things for the first time and
seeing
everything you've been working towards
happen
i love it and i love how you're
describing it so systematically and that
there was a lot of intentionalities and
and goes back to what you said a few
minutes ago about celebrating those
small wins and and looking at those
small wins and celebrating them
company-wide and being really
intentional about
about the way that you're interacting
with them
you know fast forward a few years you
know you're selling to francis vadoo for
500 million dollars which is
you know an incredible milestone not not
just for beijing but for the israeli
ecosystem as a whole and and with an
amazing journey
what was you know if you're looking back
now
about yourself and you as the leader and
as an entrepreneur
what were some non-trivial things that
you learned about leadership and about
either your own style of leadership or
leadership that you've observed you know
company-wide in any facet
that it's not trivial that you didn't
really expect it coming into this
journey
mom i think there was a lot i learned a
lot um
i learned
that
first of all it's important to be an
all-around player in the beginning
and i think over time it's really
important to delegate and find the right
people who have the responsibility over
every single field that you need to
focus on
um i think the growth from a startup to
a larger company right i come from a
startup that turned into corporate world
and if you ask me the most fun is the
startups phase
um
but when you go into the corporate world
or
into the larger company
phase you really need to consider
how to maintain the company's culture
and how to maintain um
you know the vibes and the family
atmosphere even as you grow and take
care of every single employee because
the employees are really what as cliche
as it sounds right they're really what
makes the company
was that a topic of conversation about
how to retain the culture and the
mindset of an early stage company as
you're growing and growing
definitely um we brought an
organizational consultant and at some
point when we got to about 110 people
we really wanted to
i always say i feel like i'm in catcher
in the rye the book i don't know if you
read it where he's trying to stop the
people from falling off so
so i'm trying to to keep us in this
small
uh atmosphere where everything is you
know you walk in you don't
walk in without saying good morning and
you walk in and you meet people at the
coffee area and
um you get excited at lunch you know
with different people so i really think
it's really nice to be a tight-knit
company
um and i also think that as a tight-knit
company i think things run faster like i
don't want to get to the point where
things are heavy to move you know you
want to keep them going fast and you
want the quick action and the ability to
keep up with the pace of the industry
and even beat it right
was this entrepreneurial bug also always
a part of you you know joining joining
your previous company's first employee
and joining this company is a co-founder
you know is where were you always even
at 22 when you came
and and you entered into the marketing
world was this always sort of the
strategy and the vision that you want to
you know you want to be a core part of
of new companies
i think i acquired it over time
uh initially i think in matomi i didn't
expect it to be as long of a ride as it
was when i looked back at those 10 years
yeah
when i looked back at those 10 years
i enjoyed mostly when we were small or
when i started you know there i also
opened the china branch and an india
branch and that was the excitement of
really
building something and seeing the impact
of what you're doing
so
once i left there i realized how much i
enjoy it and there's nothing more
rewarding than looking back and
and seeing what you've done and and also
of course looking forward and knowing
that it can get so much bigger
but um incredible i i mean if you ask me
now there's definitely in my you know
for me there's a great deal of
excitement in creating
karen i want to just thank you for for
these 20 minutes of just pleasure and
and such a fun conversation about you
know entrepreneurship and about you know
this this amazing journey that you were
on multiple journeys that you were on
and uh and the huge huge you know
success at the end not just the
acquisition and not just you know the
milestones but but for me just you know
it seems like this journey was such a
joyous one that was so intentional with
so many small celebrations not just
waiting for the end result but but
really enjoying the ride and enjoying
those the the five dollar first purchase
and the first time a user engaged with
the product the first time you saw
somebody that that you knew is also
playing the game that's not your family
or or close friend and so i think that's
just you know those are the moments that
i wish for myself when i all go on my
own journey so thank you very much and
thank you for your time here and it's
just the beginning
it's just the beginning
i love it
thank you thank you
[Music]
you